well a lot of people think this is my
50th year at Grand Ole Opry it's
actually been 60 because first time I
got to sing on the Opry I was 13 years
old and actually Johnny Cash introduced
me I believe and Jimmy C Newman had
given me his spot my Uncle Bill Owens
and I used to drive from East Tennessee
all the time we'd get a loaf of bread
and pack up some canned stuff in there
pork and beans and potted meat DYI knees
you call my Vienna every way we come
down to Nashville back and forth you
know no beat-up car sleep in the
backseat go to the Grand Ole Opry wait
backstage looking at all the greats and
now that was always my dream and it was
my daddy loved the Grand Ole Opry so we
had to listen to it back home it's
amazing because when they said you know
it's your 50th anniversary you have to
do a special some people think I'm 50
years old but I can easily understand
you take my man but you don't know what
he means to me Joe
[Music]
Oh baby I'll be pleased
you never know if your dreams are gonna
come true and if they do you wonder how
people will remember you when you're
older and I'm older and I'm seeing how
people are remembering me and that makes
me feel very humble and I'm just very
honored that I'm still around not only
to just get to accept this that I can
actually perform and get out there and
still doing what I love to do and maybe
I'll be around another 50 years move
I've been doing some movies from Netflix
based on songs I've written I've done
eight shows that are gonna drop in
November and they're based on songs like
tolling and Tudor was down several songs
and then hopefully and I just did a
musical Christmas musical that'll be on
next Christmas I wrote all the songs for
that and all the dates and you know I
felt like a Broadway star but I'm
actually playing a big part in that mac
ting in that as well